what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another Game of Thrones Season
7 trailer breakdown let's not waste any
time and just get right into this the
opening shot is a scene on the beach as
some men arrive on a small boat it's
very hard to make out who this is but
there does appear to be some Dothraki on
the beach so I'm going to assume this is
at Dragonstone this could be Jon Snow
and Davos arriving so they can meet
Daenerys Targaryen and retrieve some
dragon class John has been telling all
the northern Lords he needs to get
dragon class to fight the night king and
even later in the trailer you can hear
him addressing everyone in talking about
Daenerys and her dragons John will want
Daenerys and her dragons on his side for
the long night but some of the other
northerners will not want to trust a
Targaryen and this is going to be the
cause of the revolt that John has to
face next you can hear Daenerys say she
was born to rule the Seven Kingdoms and
this could be her speaking at her own
small council meeting or she could be
saying this to John Snow in the last
preview trailer we could see Daenerys
planning her attack with Tyrion Yara
Theon gray were missandei Lauria Varys
and Lady Olenna she may be saying this
quote at that meeting but in the next
scene Cersei Lannister has begun a
meeting of her own with randyll Tarly
his son and several other Lords he has
brought to fight for her cause randyll
Tarly is Sam Carly's father who was a
strong supporter of the Tyrells in Lady
Olenna but now that Lady Olenna has
sided with Daenerys Targaryen Cersei
will help term the tarly's against her
and you can hear Cersei saying Daenerys
will destroy the realm and they must
stand together if they are going to stop
her the Lannisters are starting to gain
some alliances now and they will have
randyll Tarly and his forces plus euron
greyjoy and his forces randyll Tarly is
one of the greatest battle commanders of
all time so with these new alliances
Cersei should have she should be able to
put up a much better fight against an
heiress things are starting to get very
interesting now and all-out war is on
the horizon my friends but next we go up
north and pay a visit with Jon Snow at
Winterfell where training has begun to
prepare everyone for the night king and
the storm he's about the brain the kids
are in the courtyard training with the
bows already and John wasn't kidding
when he said he needed every man woman
and child ready to fight as we see the
training yard we can hear Jon
sno say we can't defeat the night king
on her own Daenerys has Dragon Fire John
deciding to ask Daenerys Targaryen for
help is going to become a big problem in
the north the northerners do not like
the Targaryen 's Daenerys his father the
Mad King burned Ned Stark's father alive
Annie murdered Ned Stark's brother was
some kind of device that choked him to
death plus everyone thinks the nares his
brother Rhaegar kidnapped and raped Leon
a stark there aren't gonna be many
people in the north wanting a Targaryen
around the north is definitely about to
be in a revolt when John leaves to meet
the dragon queen Davos tells everyone
that if we don't band together we are
gonna die but that isn't gonna be enough
to convince everyone right away everyone
in the north is gonna need to see the
dead marching for themselves to change
their mind and realize they do need all
the help that they can get but until
then John may have a big problem on his
hands and with Littlefinger putting more
seeds of doubt in everyone's mind while
he is gone people might start to think
about ever throwing Jon Snow his king
especially when bran stark gets back
home brain stark is the last living
legitimate male Stark things are gonna
get interesting in the north and brain
might show up in the next episode and
really turn the north on their heads I'm
really excited for this next episode now
but let's move on the trailer moves
along very fast after this so let's go
through the quick clips first we see
Daenerys Targaryen sitting on our throne
and we saw this in the first trailer - I
think this is when John and Davos
arrived at Dragonstone and meet with
Daenerys for the first time when Davos
says we need to band together or we will
die he could be saying this to Daenerys
as well as of right now the nurse isn't
quite aware of the threat beyond the
wall but Melisandre shows up - and
Melisandre will help convince the nares
about the real war that's coming
Melisandre might even show Daenerys
something in the flames to help prove it
to her
then we see Cersei standing up off the
throne and it looks like Euron is right
there next to the throne as well this
might be when Euron arrives back in
King's Landing with his brand-new gift
for the Queen and as I've said before
Euron's gift will be some prisoners that
Cersei will love to get her hands on
then we see the blade get sharpening
again and we've seen this blade sharpen
in three trailers now so this must be a
pretty significant but I have no idea
who this could be I can only assume it's
an important scene because they keep
showing it then we see the unsullied
storming the castle occasionally rock
Tyrion will most likely plan this attack
because not only will
you know how to get in and catch them
with their guard down but Tyrion will
tell them to cut off Circe's other
forces in her only place to run I think
we would see the battle at Casterly Rock
on the next episode next we go down into
the crypts where is another clip of Jon
Snow choking the [ __ ] outta Littlefinger
before John leaves Winterfell to go
south John will go down into the crypts
to visit with family before he leaves
Littlefinger will come down and talk his
[ __ ] and get his ass beat Littlefinger
might say something about Ned or Sansa
or even question the way John has been
ruling in the north Littlefinger is
pushing his luck in the north and it's
just a matter of time before someone
removes him from the equation we then
see your on riding through the streets
of King's Landing and it appears he has
some kind of rope in his hands Euron
will have someone tied up behind him as
he parades them through the streets of
King's Landing and takes them right to
the Queen Cersei as his gift to form
this new alliance I'm not gonna spoil it
here but let's just say Cersei is gonna
be very pleased with his gift
now this next scene is very dark but it
does look like Cersei and Jaime are
incest ting some more now this is
nothing new
sir she's gonna use sex to get Jaime to
do whatever it is that she wants she
treats him like [ __ ] until she needs him
and after this Jaime will go attack
wherever the hell she wants which will
most likely be Highgarden because we
heard them talking about Highgarden in
the first episode Jaime said he doesn't
have enough food to feed his men and
horses but Highgarden does Cersei
already hates the Tyrells anyway and now
that they are siding with the Targaryen
that once Cersei removed from power this
is gonna be an easy decision to make in
the next clip Daenerys Targaryen is
outside overlooking the sea and she
turns her head to look at someone
walking up to her and this was probably
going to be Jon Snow
they are gonna discuss the real threat
north of the wall and Daenerys will
probably tell John that she is there for
one reason and one reason only I think
it's going to take a little bit of time
to convince to get Daenerys to take her
dragons up north into the snow then we
see Varys woke up he said Melisandre
which is very interesting because Varys
is typically terrified of the red
priestesses this is another scene that
was in the trailer this is when
Melisandre watches as a group of people
walk up to the castle of Dragonstone
this will probably be Jon Snow and Davos
arriving to meet the Queen and discuss
them getting some dragonglass now I'm
kind of glad Melisandre is here because
Melisandre can help convince Daenerys
that the night king is the true threat
but as we all know Davo
hates the red woman and wants to kill
her for sacrificing princess Shireen
this may end up being a very tense scene
when her and Davos meet again but they
might have to put aside their
differences for now and focus on the
real war that's coming because
Melisandre told John that she can still
help him with this war and they might
actually need her Theon and Yara are
under attack that's led by euron greyjoy
and Aria look scared as [ __ ] while she's
out in the woods and I think this is
when the wolf comes up behind her and
starts to growl but I think this is one
of the Wolves from Nymeria spec so Arya
is gonna be all right once Nymeria comes
out from the trees and I really hope
they instantly reconnect and Arya is
able to give her a big hug right away
the next scene shows a group of people
walking up to the castle in Dragonstone
and I think this is going to be John
Davos and Tyrion walking up to meet with
Daenerys and this is who Melisandre is
watching from above one important scene
that comes up next is what Littlefinger
and Sansa Littlefinger is going to cause
some real problems for Jon while he is
gone Littlefinger is gonna try as hard
as to splinter their relationship they
show songs are walking away from the
weirwood tree again and if you've seen
my trailer breakdown video then you know
it looks like someone is out here at the
tree with Sansa and I think it's brand
sitting in his chair at first I was
thinking bran might tell her about
Littlefinger out here in all his [ __ ]
but with everything going on in the
north now bran might tell songs about
Jon's real parents and this could be a
problem for Jon with everyone in the
north rising up against him already
if people find out he's a Targaryen they
might want to kill him now I don't think
they ever well but depending how things
play out will decide how far they're
gonna go with this plot if bran shows up
and exposes little finger and then
little finger is killed
it might quiet things down some in
Winterfell until Jon can get back and at
least defend himself but once that wall
comes down it's not gonna matter whose
blood you have everyone will need to
stand together just like Davos said or
they won't stand a chance against the
night king but the biggest scene from
this trailer in my opinion is at the
very end
Daenerys meets with Melisandre while
Melisandre tells Daenerys I believe you
have a role to play as does another and
this was very cool I think Melisandre is
going to help convince the Narus that
she needs to team up with Jon Snow and
fight the night King mo assange is gonna
see some more [ __ ] in the flames and
know that these two are needed to fight
together we know that jon is going to be
going north of the wall where he
encounters the army of the
and in one of those scenes you can see
fire behind the whites and I'm thinking
that has to be Dragon Fire I'm not
really sure how fires that big would get
that far up north
unless Melisandre tells Daenerys she is
needed to go up north to help John -
this whole thing just got a hell of a
lot more interesting in my opinion
Melisandre has always been that wild
card whether you love her or hate her
and she may really come into use now but
I don't want to go into spoiler
territory in this video so I'm gonna
save some stuff for another video that
way I can talk freely with all of you
who do like spoiler talk so for now I'm
gonna end this video here and start
working on another video although this
trailer was short it was really
effective John is going to face a revolt
in the north just like the description
for the episode said sir she's gonna get
another alliance with the tarly's and
send them in Jamie down south to start a
war and Euron Greyjoy is going to attack
Theon and Yara and bring back Cersei her
gift
once again Littlefinger is up to no good
convincing Sansa that Jon needs to be
stopped and removed as king but bran
Stark is going to arrive very soon and
turn everything on its head
and Jon and Daenerys are about to meet
very soon as well which will be the
beginning stages for the end game with
those two fighting together against the
one true enemy of the north I'm very
excited for the upcoming episodes now it
does look like things are gonna move at
a very faster pace and I can't wait so
thanks for stopping by everyone and
watching today's video
comment down below and let me know what
you think about everything in this new
trailer have a good day and I'll see you
down in the comment section bye